blattmann numero 18 e non ci credo
ragazzi tra non so fa la matematica per
avete capito manca poco quando il natale
quando tale condendo tale tra tra tra
trat
mancano gli ultimi sei rom mans e
finiamo tutto non vedo l'ora
prima di iniziare però con questa
giornata
devo aprire lui forme iniziato ad aprire
il regalo di luigi mi ha spiegato essere
una roba a più fasi
non ho idea di come funzioni so solo che
dovrà aprire due cose non ho idea
vabbè facciamone ad avere una certa ok
devo tirare su mesto no devo tirare
questo prima di continuare col blog
posso chiedervi solamente così un minuto
di silenzio per lui
per lui grazie al suo pop confuso e
addio che cosa ieri ma non avevo manco
la colazione piano che carino questo gol
da palle riga che palla per i ragazzi
così che c'è so che ci siete ai commenti
io no intendo c'è c'è che mi invento io
fischioni devo inventare io adesso
questo per fargli il regalo di natale è
il regalo di compleanno che lui va a
cinque giorni dopo natale e perdonatemi
se mi lamento se oso lamentarmi essere
in grado intanto vanno dietro
sono venuto a casa dei miei fratelli e
che mi aspetta nella sua cuccetta
[Musica]
prende una pallina lo so già la notte
sei allontanato da me cercano di andare
sta con me che se non s'ha da fare ma
niente sogni lontano
va beh la cosa che faccio la tua cuccia
tienimi a cuccia non è vero sarà la
cuccia chiara di come era stato scritto
ma se tu fai caro a bordo che cosa
succede
bene un pochino se facciamo questo caro
buldo caro bordo cane ecco questo fa sta
succedendo lì ma essa mara no vi prego
no no no no io c'ho preso paura che
alzino bianco improponibile e in cui
youporn
quando uno apre e vedi il best il
desktop si prevede che dica si aspetta
felitta o ciao che dici e quando uno
guarda il desktop assolutamente abbiate
sospetto qualcosa perché mangiano
abbiamo utilizzato che vuol dire che
gabriele cosa vuol dire chi ha mangiato
che avevamo sceneggiato e chiave non
piacciono inutilizzati ma tutti i
compiti omogenizzati vabbè qualcuno ma
che c'hai frutta pollo
beh che non ti piacciono da trent'anni
ma ci sono degli omogeneizzati un in
frigo finire era l'ultimo ma che era con
ip all mangia nipiol perché questi sono
le sottomarche manzo ma che si è
mangiato quindi l'omogeneizzato col
manzo enrico sisti bambini di viziano
proprio che schifo la nei europa mamma
mia
vuoi attaccarti al mio seno gabetto 6
mutande sta cercando in tutti i modi di
dire un inquadrarsi deputati le bombe
sondando organismi caccia al tesoro ne
abbiamo diciamo un divertimento di
famiglia che quello di fare una caccia
al tesoro
scusa ma riusciamo a farla secondo te
tipo in un blog ma alla fin qui alla
fine hanno chiesto l'aiuto
ma gianluigi uno è venuto avvocato ha
educato sì questo sono stato io lo sai
che ti ho mandato tutta una scusa ma che
cela due settimane comunque ho notato
che nessuno nessuno convinto stato nella
stanza davis cerca di tutti ma di non
far vedere questo posso dire magazzino
pareti vedo di sbagliato se mi piange il
cuore ho deciso di imbucarsi insomma
così così come catherine in montagna ci
sono gli strani e al di là della
barriera guarda qua si chiama tette
resti sempre da tomb raider col ragazzi
sentite questi mancati sia esso non può
leggere lo metterà la calzamaglia che
devo fare
capello ci stanno i tamburi tutti si sa
la gente che tirano al capri ora andiamo
a rocca priora casa gabriele perché
delle spade katana questo non camminano
molti come si difende la casa se non hai
un arma vicina a letto con lui
scherzi a parte prima che possa passare
un messaggio sbagliato mio fratello è
uno stuntman professionista questo vuol
dire che è casa nostra è sempre stata
piena di bastoni e spade scudi
paracaduti cioè è veramente qualsiasi
cosa temo adesso tirato fuori sta cosa
che no ma che succede rocca priora la
divisa da smau se vuoi ma perché ma
secondo da rocca priora affidati rocca
priora e il posto
va bè questo me lo porto comunque questa
cosa qui un gay e che hanno tante volte
rocca
vediamo st rocca priora che poi se tu
parli con quelli di rocca priora
sentieri questa cosa ti dico ok rocca
priora è il paese più alto dei castelli
romani ho capito ma che minas tirith
reti dicono così è nido dell'aquila ok
che il più alto ma mica sono dolomite
750 metri di dislivello
rocca priora in realtà una puntata di
super barca e tipo loro fanno che fa ma
oggi sembra prende il caffè tipo fanno
andava a funghi e che succede vanno a
fare i funghi io sono pronto a fare
conti gabriele mi ha fatto portare la
tuta da sci di gianluigi inutile dirvi
che statuta non esservi tankan dove si
chiamano ma cos'è sta rocca priora
parlapiano perché trovo lodevole anche
questa macchina non hanno mai visto
macchine minuti non hanno mai visto
vacchi sanno manco mai visto una persona
famosa
che vuol dire una persona famosa come te
ci sarà il sindaco di rocca priora con
con lafasciano canale 9 con favore gli
pare e mi pare che si dica roccapriorese
penso ma mi abbia detto rocca fiorese si
dica
va beh non è compreso la lingua
ovviamente parla in elfico forte siamo
pari alla scala camera
basta finiti e abbassa la camera bassa
quindi quindi padre noi da subito
due piccole accortezze
ok qui
voglio che tu non faccia numerati
stupido con gli indigeni del posto a
tempo scaduto non fare movimenti con la
camera fai parlare me ok
indietro
proviamo a dare conforto indigeno del
posto
pronto seguimi di genere posso seguire
[Musica]
futuro
facevo la fiducia pro spaventarla col
fuoco
ok benvenuti in diretta abbiamo
recuperato due esemplari di mammiferi
nuovo saranno sentite sentite i loro
vecchi pc tipici non ho capito dove ci
dobbiamo mettere rito questo è padrone
si ok ok detto anche tu che ideo
lasciando merse un'usanza di locali
il tuo nome gabriele sono nega ma che
modo
ma è normale anzi mi scusi
cerco di rendermi l'amica anch'io
posso dire una cosa che in questo posto
ci stanno
bistecche presente appese ovunque
ho scritto vagliati non esistono che non
esistono
vieni espulso la notte barocca proteica
[Risate]
[Musica]
come voi se venite a roma
rifate la foto col play alloro al
colosseo
quando non andava quindi faceva figlia
e un giorno mio nonno e rientrare così
iberico un giorno mia nonna
c'era viola di questa cosa perché faccia
di melo anche valente lettore dolce sono
dei funghi l'ha visto gli ha lanciato
invece di che si sono complicate unico
stato come gesù cioè praticamente qua la
gente fa fatica a scuola e adesso sei
andato a funghi anche oggi
breve riassunto della serata dopo aver
mangiato sono tornate a casa di manuela
lei federica e mio fratello si sono
messi a parlare della caccia al tesoro
mentre invece sono rimasto col gatto che
sembra più un labrador dal livello
distanza di emanuela al piano di sopra e
non so cosa abbiano fatto allora era
soltanto in questa seduta a tu style a
berlino credendo così di vetto colpi li
senti fai la promessa alla camera che
cosa che tu non le vedrai le clip queste
qui del cassero e posso dire con
orgoglio che ho mantenuto la promessa
sapete
guardate che faccia che questo di questo
frame
foggia una pupilla che è una moneta da
due euro ma che sono tornato a casa con
maglietta con sotto la maglietta termica
il mio fratello è che non so cosa
aspettarsi veramente molti kanik ho
messo le mie creme di tristezza è che
dire
dopo aver scoperto la ridente e persa
nel tempo
rocca priora mi metterò a dormire
noi ci vediamo domani con un altro blog
mas sempre alle 14